herzlich willkommen zurück bei easy
german ich bin auf dem rhein auf einer
fähre in meiner neuen heimatstadt in
basel in der schweiz und werde gleich
mal wenn wir angekommen sind die
schweizer fragen was sie so über
deutschland und die deutschen denken
haben sie viele deutsche fahrgäste ja
wie sind die so angenehm anständig
freundlich manchmal bisserl knausrig
knauserig wollen sie den fahrpreis von 1
franken 60 nicht bezahlen ja oder sie
sagten wenn die mit euro zahlen jahr ist
es nicht günstig reparieren oder so
irgendwie seid ihr hier aus basel
li na also dass aber auch die schweiz
richtig was denkt ihr als schweizerinnen
über deutsche und deutschland ehrlich
sie wirken etwas arrogant warum sie
reden sei überheblich und auch die art
wie sie mit den menschen umgehen also
auch initiiert das bestellen zum
beispiel kommt immer sehr arrogant rüber
die frage nicht darf ich ein café sie
sagen ich kriegen kaffee so sachen
erstürmt durchkriegen café stimmt das
sagen die deutschen die schweizer seien
es etwas höflicher etwas ja dann könnte
ich abends ihren kaffee könnte ich einen
kaffee haben kaffee bitte dass ich im
café aber ich glaube dass ich nicht bös
gemeint
und wenn man die mentalität von den
deutschen nicht kennt dann werde man das
negativ für sich so ein bisschen
aufbrausende menschen
inwiefern die familie von meinem
freundes tempo und deutschland deswegen
sind so bisschen party party
ich finds geil mallorcas ist wirklich
gut drauf sie heute schluss stieg mit
einer fusion ihre beziehung zu
deutschland
sie können zwar möglichst rasch
interessiert
aha
ja das ist schweiz nicht so
der fc basel ist noch ziemlich extrem
starke aber sonst
ich kenne mich mit fußball nicht so aus
was ist da das vorurteil dass die
deutschen besser sind im fußball oder
was ist nicht ein vorteil es ist fakten
unseren nachbarn ok und wie sind die so
anders oder wie sind sie gleich was
unterscheidet euch von denen sie ist ein
relativ direkt mehr als 70 zunehmend
zurückhalten und die die ganze sache
wenn es läuft in flotter die deutschen
sind ruckzuck zack zack heißt es da da
gibt es kabarett sendungen wo die
deutschen an hochgenommen werden
aufgrund ihrer art und weise aber wenn
man dann hört in überall wo sie arbeiten
die deutschen sie handeln andere art zu
bearbeiten und sind dann manchmal zu
korrekt ich glaube die leute hier sind
welt freuen freundlich als in
deutschland
mein bruder hat ein austausch gemacht in
deutschland unterhält kein kollegin
doris gemacht meine freunde gefunden
also für mich denkt sympathisch und ich
habe mit ihnen auch gearbeitet und dem
von dem her
sie gehören zu unserer gesellschaft
eigentlich positivste von
auslandssemestern gemacht in berlin wo
wie was da habe ich gelebt drei jahre
lang
ok also cool als nationale auf wechsel
sie hat jetzt eine karte mehr
ich bin katholik ist das muss zu
erklären was das ist
swiss life de morales auch in einem
kontinent alles ist wirklich alles jeder
hätte aziz eigenen channels merkel offen
ja das ist so vertrauens ist musik ist
offen mit zuständig dass die schweiz
schon sehr an unsere schemata klima
sachen agent kannst du das bestätigen
und sie sind irgendwie selbstbewusster
aber das hängt zusammen
ich bin eigentlich da unterschied machen
man panik dankbar dass sie besser sind
nur schlachters irgendeiner posten
einfach menschen wären also ich sag
immer in jeder nationalität gibt es
lustige und nicht so lustig hier gehört
für den lustiger und werden wir treffen
auf nun lustige verletzt kommt gerade
deutscher kollege aus stuttgart der
stiftung jetzt auch noch eines kontaktes
auf die ausbildung auf tv hat das
intellekt was eine von einer hand der
nation denkt also also ich denke man
kann sich vor allem ich verstehe mich
als europäer also wissen ein kultur die
schweiz deutschland und österreich haben
die gleiche sprache
die gleiche kultur weshalb ich nicht so
wesentliche unterschiede sehen
also ich habe eigentlich keine ahnung
wir sind nur ein paar stunden hier
gewesen wir waren noch nie in der
schweiz
also was ist das bild wie denken die
schweizer über die deutschen
ich denke als auch in ihren über
schweizer und deutsche sehr positiv
ich gehe gerne bei euch einkaufen
einfach günstige und ich seid nett nicht
so demokratisch aus der schweiz ein
anderes regierungssystem ich meine das
hat dann schon ein fluss ein anderes
schulsystem auf die kultur oder auch die
menschen ja ich meine hartz4 ist schon
übel also meinst du dass sie die schweiz
besten bessere sozialsystem hat oder
weiß ich gar nicht ich kann sich zur
abschätzung immer ein ein vorurteil dass
die deutschen mit den schweizern haben
ist dass es hier irgendwie allen gut
geht und das geht manchmal schon recht
auf den sack weil das leben hier auch
nicht einfach also zu dieser idee die
schweizer würden da so in saus und braus
leben
es gebe keine probleme keine sozialen
probleme ist schon ziemlich verzerrtes
bild
wo würdest du wenn du dich für den rest
seines lebens für ein land entscheiden
ist das motto leben müsste es dann wäre
das nicht die klink schwer ich glaube
ich wo besteht sowie ein konkurrenzkampf
ihr mit der eu halt alles und wir
weigern uns das betrifft und dann denke
ich vielleicht müssen sie immer ein
extra wurst haben keine ahnung wer zwei
jahren kein problem da gibt es andere
staaten probleme was aber abschottung
finde ich immer schlecht
also für mich als deutscher der in die
schweiz gezogen ist nach basel ist es
schön zu hören dass die schweiz einen
grossen und ganzen doch ein positives
bild über die deutschen haben zumindest
hier in der grenzregion in basel
falls ihr gedanken zu dem thema habt
schreibt uns in die kommentare
und wir sehen uns demnächst bis bald